welcome to a new episode of not too deep
I'm your host grace and helping the
first we have half of the valley folk
here with us today we have elliott
morgan and joe bereta and it's just a
gosh-dang lovely episode also Jill
brought his kin his child is muttering
around in the background if you hear
anything and added a lot of flavor to
the episode also I think this might be
the first time that Eliot's ever
actively listened to anything that Jo
has said out of his mouth so it's a very
educational episode for all of us enjoy
this very fun sarcastic silly dumb
child-friendly episode of not too deep
with Joe Bereta and Elliott Morgan this
episode is brought to you by Squarespace
turn your great idea into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you're showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind they have
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything you can
easily make a beautiful website all by
yourself but if you get stuck
Squarespace is 24/7 award winning
customer support is there to help go to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you are ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain my brother told me that there is
that turtles have little living rooms in
their show I believe that for
uncomfortable amount of time yeah that
was well into adulthood to this week up
until Tuesday why did you do that that
seems like it was a bad person well
that's also very hard so adorable I'll
restart have we started we started time
we have 1/2 oak here I mean if we're
honest it's like 2/3 yeah Kevin Kevin
makes up yeah I mean as far as 1/3 and
we make up the other two gravitas that
is brought into the equation ok sex
appeal mm-hmm yeah Kevin has most of it
kevin has opposed the sexy
okay well Kevin Jesus
you should have mistakes Joe you're the
only member of the valley folk that
hasn't been on this podcast yet really
yeah I did not know that
it was on it Steve was on it that's how
we found out that he got divorced in the
real time on the podcast he's like I got
divorced a couple months ago and I've
been losing weight we all went okay but
he was a delight was he a delight he was
a goddamn delay yeah and then I
deflected and went back to talking about
like what body part would you most want
to be but also I'm happier here thank
you for helping I left it up to you guys
because we can't really it gets a little
chaotic to have more than two guests at
a time I bet so I left it up to you guys
to decide which groupings you would do
how did I know I lied I lied to Joe and
me like gray said she wants me Joe and
the lien you played God I thought it'd
be fun to do like a yin-yang thing
because Joe and I are like the I would
say quieter members and I mean I yang
Yang not within each other but a ying
yang I mean like the twins do oh yeah
yeah do got it
that's what do you mean and that's the
kind of hot stuff you can look forward
to in this episode he buckle up
everybody we're going 15 miles per hour
let us know that they're about to be
extraordinarily okay expectations are
set we've been doing this packets for
five years and I've developed a new way
in which I opened up the conversation
with guests and it's a question that I
think is um really poignant and it is
what's your deal a new way to polarize
an audience is this deal it's an
aggressive question it's heavy too if
you hang on the guest real quick is your
podcast favoring more of the the
auditory listeners or the visual both we
just started doing the visual stuff so
you can play to where everybody PC must
finish this is it yep okay yeah we
should on an iPhone oh no if you've
heard how successful I am on YouTube
it's an iPhone 6 yeah
[Music]
specifically only in portrait mode it's
just one long Instagram story it's not a
secondary iPhone it's her iPhone yeah I
really do admire that like because we we
have a crappy we have a crappy like Mevo
camera that makes it it's terrible and I
hate it very much and it makes us look
like we're in a fishbowl and this is
like better and it's an iPhone and it is
not a Mevo and that's Elliott's deal
next up on what's your deal imma let you
go first
dude you know where I can go I can go
like crazy I feel like the question is
so aggressive that I needed to answer it
defensively so I'm just gonna say how
gnomes kind of trying to do my thing my
friends and that fun and it's going fun
this year
stroke yeah that's my deal yeah yeah my
deal since I haven't been here before
been doing you do for 12 years I know
you are literally like the foundation of
YouTube and I don't think a lot of
people remember a recognization but yeah
I can watch it be built back in my kind
of orbiting it whatever cutting but it's
a ribbon for this podcast grace was like
I'm gonna lean in heavily into Joe and I
almost like definitely you do this yeah
I mean I've talked too much
I know everything you have no why I
don't know it's a weird we have a group
to not cool it wait I don't get cool
is there something not cool is there
someone well we have common in cube art
we keep our private lives off of social
media you know there's both really like
Elliott they're gonna throw up a graphic
they'll tell you everything yeah go
watch the YouTube because you're not
gonna see that on the audio one
okay here's a question that a lot of
people asked us to that I'm curious
about what was your guys's first
impression of each other do you remember
the day that you met yes I remember
meeting Joe
it was at an audition for SourceFed oh
wow in a in a run-down Hollywood not
rundown big ship a ship casting studio
yeah it's one of those like many empty
cavernous high-rises mm-hmm in Hollywood
where you go in and you throw everything
on the line which we did yeah the same
moment Wow wait did you audition
together did we read together I don't
think we did we walked out together
though I remember the moment we like
walked out of the building hand-in-hand
and yeah purposefully yeah through the
doorway at the same time we got stuck it
was a little vaudeville routine we did
and I knew we loved each other but um no
my first impression of Joe was like
literally being like this guy is like
really nice it's what you do in
Hollywood right yeah I was so nervous on
every I'm really weird back then we were
gunning for the same spot
unbeknown oh you didn't know that you
were auditioning for the same thing I
mean we knew that we were auditioning
for the same thing but you go into those
not to get into the industry crap too
much because that's not boring but you
walk into these things usually it's with
a bunch of people that looks just like
you yeah you really get a smack in the
face of what you represent to the world
oh they're like commercials for instance
and beer commercial guy and I go out for
a lot of cell phone commercials what do
you go out for where did you get I go
out for a lot of like flaky flaky
mistress uh-huh yeah actually PR
business independent woman and I just go
into cups on the side with married guys
I go in for loose morals loose there's a
child in the roof it was great oh no
he's hurting worse things yeah guys left
at the same time left at the same time I
remember thinking the same thing nice
guy but then I called my wife
immediately and I was that I'm leaving
you
he's amazing I was fine everything went
great
there's a girl named Li she touches
everybody a lot really she touched me so
inappropriately and then I learned that
it's just who she is yeah audition where
I've been like what's happening here I
need to leave like you know like she's
just assumed familiarity yeah
immediately to it's like yeah you can't
again watch the video but I had an
audition like waiting to go in and it
was to show you would just fit so did
you yeah right can I just finish it up
blah blah blah blah and there's a guy
named Elliot and it's fine and I was
like I'm gonna I'm gonna crush him I've
got this in the bag
this is true yeah I told you that Wow
yeah I got it no Phil I knew Kevin bruit
who was who's very close with Phil right
and he was kind of helping out with the
casting and he's the reason that I I
knew that they were doing it and at the
time I was working at the griddle again
another Hollywood thing that we don't
need to get into which is just big ass
pancakes on the side you know making
money for my family at the time it was
like a SourceFed came around and I was
at a point in my life and you're
gambling in debt and I was like I need I
need to take a chance and then SourceFed
was kind of like the the risk it was a
joke because they never knew it was
gonna become what it became no we all
thought I was gonna be six months and
how long was it two years I left Tigers
in and then you left about six months
after that and then we was he was out
yeah
like four years five sort spent in
various iterations lasted five or six
years Elliott left after two and I left
after three pieced out yeah it's insane
I don't think people really recognize
like how much work went into the content
that you guys make I remember I got
invited to come in one day and I was
like we've been here since 6:00 a.m. and
I was like you guys are stupid and then
you guys sit like in a real writers room
and pitch ideas and then literally write
them up and shoot it and it's a product
that's made like in-house in a couple
hours it's insane how much you guys made
literal hours yeah yeah yeah the first
one would be like shot entirely by 7:00
a.m. and it wouldn't have been written
until we got in at sex so it was written
and shot in an hour and then uploaded by
9:00 9:00 a.m. was the first way the
typical day nine eleven one yeah yeah
the typical day for the first two years
was show up at 6:00 the three of us yeah
show up at 6:00 steve zaragoza of the
valley folk jumped in seven eight months
down the line we would show up at the
same hotel situation we would post five
videos in a day those five videos would
be researched closed fingers
regurgitated into script shot and edited
and posted all of them by like 5:00 p.m.
yeah by the three of us and two editors
yeah yeah it was it was a groundbreaking
[Laughter]
digital space that we all get to exist
in and profit off of today because
that's insane that schedules nuts but
also conducive to efficiency and
productivity what was it like after you
guys left this is like an actual like
interview I didn't we should do like a
structure like you guys have like a
chemistry going between you two I'm
really surprised it's more of a biology
I feel yeah I get it so I don't know
what's going on here but basically how
yeah afterwards yeah I think there's two
different paths I'll let Elliot go I
feel he was a little more lost than I
was I got confused this is what your
question was I'm sorry what did you say
after you guys are done
with such an intense schedule what was
it like when you left and you had free
time and you didn't have to be in an
office at 6:00 a.m. Oh after we left
SourceFed yeah
very like I don't know this is a this is
like a serious answer but it was very
like because I left it was always like
should I have not left and so I was very
haunted by it for a very long time very
much he made the right decision yeah and
we were skyrocketing we actually had a
big jump after Elliot exactly yeah and I
bet there were those who did that yeah I
just remember being like I don't want to
be I don't want to only do this one
thing or be known for this one thing and
I you know and then then I started doing
stand-up and I love stand-up very much
and then I got divorced and that became
my full-time job with most of your
stealing through divorces and yeah it
was the gift that kept giving and yeah
and so that was what I did and then it
was kind of like SourceFed SourceFed
intended and then odd job - odd job and
then divorce where I blacked out for two
years I popped out and then we all got
back together again yeah that was that
was that was my yeah something had some
stuff happened in between but a true
hero's journey Wow yeah beautiful it was
doing the I don't mean to speak for you
but I'm going please Joe Joe I need to
speak for you you were doing the the
classic struggling to make it find my
way to make ends meet hustle in LA but
he was doing it less in the realm of
going into like mainstream auditions and
more on YouTube but you're doing like a
weird YouTube hustle and all sorts of
you at the same time because we're doing
Mental Floss search in Asheville and all
the alliteration things Mattel I think
Mattel yeah Mike and Molly I did a lot
of masturbation and masturbation was
okay what a ride yeah he looks sorry
Jack's on Lee he's fondling Lee yeah
Jackson's not paying attention Jackson's
my son Jackson's here and he's probably
creating the best content up anyone in
this room right now can you ask Jackson
what his deal is Jackson what's your
deal yes right yeah whatever it is yeah
you gotta avoid Authority I fully
respect that and support that what was
your what happened to you after you left
sir I went the opposite route I got
married again I left with opportunity in
hand no I kind of was at a point in life
that was it was a mini midlife crisis
where I realized yeah this could either
be correct or wrong that at some point
people weren't gonna want to watch the
me in front of the camera so I wanted to
go behind the camera and be able to
produce similar and and flex those
skills and build those muscles and I got
offered a creative director gig at Smosh
oh yes Smosh heard of him Internet giant
rhett and Link smosh smosh now and i was
there for three years just making shows
and hiring yeah you and I have a very
hilarious DM chain back and I asked you
to be on I forgot 10 like 10 different
things it was always a very sweet
Pleasant hey how are you would you fly
up to San Francisco and shoot this thing
of me like four days later good honest
hi I can't do it and then two months
later be like hey how are you it'd be
fair to be fair Jersey I respected your
hustle I really honestly tried to make
it all work every time I'd never lied to
you
that I can remember about avoiding reply
oh yeah
we didn't know each other like we knew
of each other but that's also how like
the whole eat their system community
seem to work that you go up and you talk
to someone and that mean that's
literally how we operated this podcast
for the first three years is me just
DMing people going will you come to my
house and talk to me pulling back the
clues on Grace and i's relationship I
don't know what you two have going this
is like 99.99% of all of our
conversations that we've ever had yeah
grace and I we're talking but we were
like oh it's fun cuz like we want to all
hang out but I was like oh the first
time we were hanging out as a unit we're
trying to get to know each other and I'm
also very like what do you think 40%
we're about 40% on I think we're doing
pretty good yeah no this is on the
normal version yeah yeah no that is I
know you guys are God bless your souls I
love Hannah memory very deeply very much
and have deep respect for themselves as
humans
[Music]
yeah the sassy redhead and then the one
that looks like Tyler Oakley no I don't
have to tell her other people she goes
into all the auditions that Tyler Oakley
is that yes Tyler passes on she goes I
got one but we've all kind of
collectively as creators that work
together I have reached like I have
figured out that we can spend a certain
amount of time together and then we all
have to let go our own ways to tolerate
each other
VidCon going with this grace and I don't
feel comfortable all right and then I'll
pivot no nope you hate the most and why
yeah I mean he does the Lord's work
truly he really does he's the glue well
the conversation I think I've asked you
guys this separately before like what
was the initial conversation when you
guys left that you were like we should
we're all just flopping around what if
we do something together it was like
that scene in Mighty Ducks 2d - you guys
formed a Flying V when when the
character a vermin is finding like the
fourth member of the Mighty Ducks team
and he says the quack attack is back
jack you all recall and the greatest
cinematic writing pain level and yeah it
was it was basically I just really
needed a job and like I felt like I
think other people also I think you
needing a job ended up being that became
the catalyst for the thing that we don't
wanted to do yeah
Elliot pushed a lot from behind the
scenes at the start again because he was
struggling and he was in debt and he was
hurting we would consider rock-bottom
and wouldn't get out of our lives
yep yeah the more or less yeah I mean
it's where it was at and this is
something that we wanted to do we knew
it whatever reasons we didn't do it be
that insecurity or for me personal life
like I have a family to support I got I
need health insurance I need all these
things so risks are riskier for me than
yeah it's just different we're we're all
in different realms of our lives and he
pushed it a lot and then I started
pushing with you a lot and then we were
pushing a lot and sourcefed ending even
though none of us were there except for
Steve at the time oh yeah
was this it was kind of this beacon that
made us realize there's still a need for
this there's still a woman and if we get
together we can capitalize on it and
then we didn't and sugar Pines seven did
yeah so anyway the young ones were doing
better than what we were doing back to
the podcast mischances yeah I'm here
with Kim and James
um we are in a very good place that
we're very happy about but man if we
would have launched our patreon the day
after you guys killed on page at live
screen that was yeah that was all part
of we were gonna do it the whole point
of the patreon was to get enough to be
able to go do my job basically which
required you know making sure there was
like health insurance making sure Joe's
family was taken care of and so that
became the primary thing that like we
had to orchestrate everything around but
then the goal was basically just like if
we could get anything on patreon we
could then like to reduce that from the
amount of the investment that we would
be asking for from somebody and then the
patreon thing happened and we were like
oh we can just start yeah and it took us
a few months to get our act together but
then yeah and we're still getting it
together but we're figuring it out a
year yeah you're a little bit more than
a year since we launched the patreon
we're kind of like in the midst of when
we a year anniversary of when we started
to kind of create some content the real
content the real content anniversary is
May soirée absolutely not we don't plan
that we don't don't
yeah you don't acknowledge
accomplishments in ourselves or
financial means yeah all of these things
on that really positive optimistic
motivating inspiring note we're gonna
take a quick break when we get back we
have more questions for those guys from
the thing no no I feel like you guys
have this like weird goodbye we'll take
it offline okay
[Music]
this episode of not too deep is brought
to you by hum at nutrition they are all
about making you look and feel your best
each specific supplement packs a combo
of potent ingredients designed for
specific aims like clear skin boosted
energy or fuller hair and is backed by
clinical results hum focuses on
preventing concerns and long-term care
and repair not damage control and
covering up their insight our approach
to beauty goes beyond a skin care
regimen alone to give you great results
hums products are sustainably sourced
non-gmo and free of soy gluten
artificial colors and preservatives plus
lots of vegan options you can try
supplements like the daily cleanse hair
sweet hair growth gummies uber energy
and more if you aren't sure what you
need go to home nutrition comm slash get
underscore started to take a quiz and
get personalized recommendations from
humm's team of registered dieticians to
make things even easier hum offers a
monthly vitamin subscription that's
affordable flexible and convenient go to
humm nutrition calm / get underscore
started for your personalized
recommendations and get 20% off your
purchase with code grace that's home
nutrition calm / get underscore started
and code grace this episode 90 was
brought to you by Squarespace
turn your dream into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project if
you're looking to start a new business
showcase your work published content sub
products and more Squarespace is the
tool for you
they have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks you can easily make a beautiful
website all by yourself Plus Squarespace
is powerful ecommerce functionality it
lets you sell anything online and they
have analytics that help you grow your
site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box and there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever buying domains is
simple and you'll get the help you need
with Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support they empower millions
of people from designers to lawyers
artists gamers restaurants gyms etc to
turn great ideas into something real go
to Squarespace
komm such grace for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch use the
offer code grace to save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain
that's squarespace.com slash grace offer
code grace thank you to our sponsors
we're back hey Squarespace I bet it was
you thanks so much
if you need design anyone can do it
award-winning customer service 24 hours
a day 7 days a week Squarespace calm
there's no grades ok what was the first
baby that you held this one caused pause
while the other actual question no mine
is probably my niece that is don't the
baby worth remembering might have been
some prior to that not been the nephew
FM my niece yeah yeah I'd like I
probably a second cousin would be my
guess I I was like the youngest first
cousin and then the second cousin
started popping out barranco lurch and
yeah I think it was my cousin cool
what was your first baby I black that
all out I'm self aware enough in my
trust of myself and my abilities I fall
down constantly so my inability to hold
my own body up leads me to believe I
should not be held accountable for
holding another Chad yeah yeah I still
have the instinct if I'm holding a baby
- sit down - well yeah yeah potato turns
out yeah I still sit down like a child
though like if you hand me a new baby
I'll be like I'm just gonna stay on the
couch to make sure I don't drop it
because if I drop it it'd be really bad
you start swaddling it but you wrap it
up the entirely wrong yeah I make it
like a yo-yo and it just sort of falls
okay what was the first internet trend
or meme that after you saw it made you
think I am very old hmm
I for me I think it was the word Yolo
when that came out I remember being like
this is stupid but I think because I
think it's stupid I am dumb an old I
think FML okay yeah yeah oh you're
talking like you guys were talking about
speaking general doesn't think slime was
another one that was gonna be my aunt
line really good one yeah and again I'm
swimming in it because my daughter is 11
and she loves it love slime yes yeah she
does it all like it's a weird hobby for
people and she's not watching a bunch of
YouTube slime videos or anything but
it's just it's in that she's not
watching it's just the culture of that
age it's huge in the schools and
everything like that digit spinners all
that crap yeah all the distraction
devices we were in school slime was also
you know the Nickelodeon days of
everything I feel like it's cyclical now
right but it was the ones gak and I
would buy it and then your parents would
get mad that it was in the carpet and
then it was gone taking the contact
solution which is really expensive thank
you thank you sink and she's like
creating but she's like duo chemist but
they're it's kind of it so it's a
lifestyle for some of these kids like
I'm a slime girl yeah but do you yeah
slime Chris weird like I feel like it
wasn't I don't feel like maybe things
took over our lives like that a little
bit more when we were younger
I mean Polly Pocket was my jam girl whoa
yeah you're a baby girl what do you call
them a little mushrooms mushrooms yeah
LSD as the Tamagotchi thinks oh yeah I
again I did and that's also where I got
like re reinforced in my brain that I
can't keep things alive
so I should not be a mother
[Music]
I mean that's what they really are
teaching kids really young like keep
this digital thing
live and if you don't it's gone forever
okay let's talk about trivia bidet
oh great this is out of all the content
that you guys make one of my favorites
because it it is exceptionally dumb and
very stupid and I no offense but
grudgingly watched an episode just to
get some knowledge of what this was for
the first time and I loved it I don't
know what it is about human in a former
life legally blind what was your first
day experience my first but day
experience I believe was in the bathroom
of Lee Newton's apartment okay well so
let me go back really quick for those
that don't know haven't experienced the
sights and sounds of trivia bidet how
would you describe it the show I guess
the title I think if you don't know what
it is
off the top the title is this titles a
little misleading because it makes me
seem like you're asking for days to
answer questions about pop culture yeah
when was the first bad day yeah or a
bidet that asks trivia questions yeah
expecting not again not today the day
have a whole schedule not today but day
is a different FX show oh that's great
it's gonna have you know spin-offs oh
it's an empire that would basically sit
on a bidet
one at a time Atlee asks you trivia
questions if you get them wrong yeah we
really went for the most convenient role
in that yo no I thought it was her idea
but no she's the host because she
refuses to be a contestant i fully
identify with that yeah it's a very
difficuit anytime it's a girl it's like
hey I've asked maybe three girls and I
always goes hey I'm I'm sorry
classy the way we film it like it's good
don't worry it's like an elegant yeah
producing you've actually become a
producer just like it's lies there's no
why I would say you film it them the
classiest way that we could possibly you
know says that verbatim producers on The
Bachelor show we want you to drink this
handle of vodka and go on this date but
we're gonna shoot it real classy you
definitely shoot a classy trivia bidet
is a trivia game show where we ask
trivia questions and if you get it wrong
you get sprayed in the booty hole yeah
there's a twist though there's a twist
are bidet unlike most bidets is
malfunctioning and shoots 22 hard and is
very cold I don't think it's
malfunctioning there's no way they all
shoot that I think they do I think you
put it in a little wrong well for all of
you just listening to the podcast this
is a curious snippet of conversation
that should be taken out of context i
the door and the walls are not there it
would hit the other side
wait so okay so this is the only bad day
both of you have ever experienced me no
I don't have a lot of experience it's
funny to me because a bidet is I guess
traditionally like a luxury amenity for
a bathroom so you're using it as
designed but it's causing wild
discomfort to the people that experience
thank you for bringing that up grace we
we are taking an upper-class
sort of thing and we're bringing it down
to the people and we're humanizing it's
our way of saying hey even if you don't
have a bidet because you're poor or
whatever you can just duct-tape a squirt
gun to the bottom of your toilet we
realize this show is purely an American
experience more internationally more
accepted mm-hmm yes we hear okay our
original plan - and I got really back in
the early days of the valley folk years
and years and years ago Jojo came up
with trivia bidet first of all and he
pitched it for months and all of us know
yeah not know but like you just
pretended he wasn't talking yeah
the valley folk functions the breed the
way the ideas see the light of day at
the valley folk is if somebody is really
excited about it and then everybody else
gets on board just enough
just enough that they show up I was
really excited about it and you really
just still truly believe in it and it it
took me doing everything to get this do
yeah it did it did for sure and for good
reason because it's it's a tough pitch
but itself I don't know about you but if
you need a new member of the valley of
focused support even build you up Joe
I'm available
holy she's there for emotional support
she will not be there tiny dogs you
bring on the plains one of those tiny
dogs yeah the original plan that was to
do a cold bidet like to have it like ice
ice-cold water
you can't you can't on fancy ones but
not just a point
make it unbearably cold which is what we
wanted and so I remember I literally
tried to like ice a pipe full of water
to make it really cold and then you
contacted our buddy Aaron Massey and
we're like is there a way she can make a
device that shoots freezing cold water
through the bidet and he was like I can
do that no problem and then you were
just like we'll just do it anyway and
then we did it synthetic custom made
someday we will know it's someday we
will yeah we're we're just in the pilot
phase right now so we shoot it in in our
legit very small office bathroom so when
we're doing a three I got three video
shoot to produce this thing we're doing
three episodes nobody gets to go to the
bathroom yeah no yeah no dad it's just
our means are very minimal sacrificing
for your art you really have to cut some
corners let me get real for a second I
really do love this show and I do think
this is gonna be our hot ones after time
doing very well for you guys cuz it's so
dumb and also I don't see anything else
like it that I'm already spinning in my
gears going
what else is a Home Depot have to offer
in the face with a hose you just try one
string one paint can yeah I had to a
ceiling see what happens you answer
wrong it works for three reasons I think
it works for sure yeah shouting frodan
hidin Frodo yeah yeah you want to see
people get be uncomfortable we do that
yep if you can trick your audience into
learning it's actually one of those
things that I think okay okay I do and I
got a lot of the things that I've
learned was you know oh crap I didn't
know that answer or you make people feel
like they're playing the game oh yeah oh
yeah yeah and then they adjust it on
different levels I mean whatever the
only thing holding it back is that maybe
it's a little perverted I mean you will
I know you guys on a personal level so
that M is overlooked but I can see how
someone that doesn't know any of you
goes this is a little bit [ __ ] up
right now super weird if you if we if we
detach ourselves from it and remove
ourselves a little bit mentally it is
definitely an incredibly weird thing we
have a lot of female friends that say no
because they're self-reflective and
smart we have a lot of self-awareness
and they're like wait a minute there's a
bunch of perverts on the internet yeah I
like this yeah what I like it may like
it way too much they unfortunately
really like this one time somebody who
didn't like we were reading you know
you've heard of negative Internet
statements before they only have a
hundred percent support from anyone that
comes across there was one guy who
referred to the valley folk as joe
bereta and his band of pervert that's a
great band name and also just I went on
a t-shirt I changed our LLC to Joe
Bereta and his band of perverts gave you
a gift
oh my god and two it was very accusatory
- it was like guys not a thing we don't
need to go into that yeah but Phil
DeFranco Phil DeFranco said it was Joe
Bradley focus just Jovi hasn't sent me
hair product I'm so angry you need to
look at the camera and say that I'm not
trying to start YouTube drama but Phil
DeFranco needs to send me some goddamn
pomade okay wow it's really I mean we're
gonna have to scrap this episode it got
real you got intense let's talk about
Stu Joe what's your Stu enthusiasm
what's this deal it's delicious last you
know Joe loves to know
thing Diane does a lot of research for
all of our guests there on the show and
I was so delighted and curious to see
what her research would be of you guys
that I know on a you know my personal
level already wait why do I follow you
on twitter thank you yeah and you're
welcome jump cut podcast yeah it's gonna
sound like an episode of Real Housewives
I'm so sorry we don't really know each
other now I feel like I might across the
world that's very good your salad I mean
Elliot enough grace stop
tell us about stew why you so
enthusiastic about it what's its deal I
don't it's just thick soup yeah it's
great it's delicious it's like smoky
it's soup that doesn't know if it wants
to be a solid or not soup with a little
bit of effort it's human it's not it's
not like a chowder based thing at least
it's more broth yeah this is a chowder
ass too
I don't what's the definition of stew
it's just stood for a long time yeah my
god I wish my interesting with this
answer it's delicious Jackson he likes
to okay thank you I'm a member of the
Jackson fan club do you not like stew I
don't have any specific feelings on it
look at Joe he's from Montana he's not a
man yeah yeah it's a manly I don't like
this box you're all putting me I also
took ballet for three years huh did you
really huh how about that for your
student your ingredients you box do you
put me you're going back to doing the
same thing we're both going back to that
I'm so sorry yeah two separate valley
folk podcasts or just to cause riffs
that's all I want you to walk away
morning hues shining a light on yeah
it's to thing I see that's tough has
there ever been an episode or a piece of
content or a podcast or anything that
never saw the light of day because
Hannah mamrie and I definitely have an
episode of my drunk kitchen that got out
of hand that has never seen the light of
day
for the valley folk we have
one piece of content that has not seen
the light of day why we just weren't
happy with it was like the one thing
that we were like we're not happy with a
lot of things that we put on but this
one like crossed a line what was it it
was the the saw parody we did good we
just want there'll be a Tuesday where
we're like [ __ ] we didn't even put on a
patron we were like this isn't even
worth we just moved on because of the
other thing is that it was kind of at
the height of us producing our your show
our mainstay show yeah I got a
consistent basis and that there's a lot
that goes into that show so ma'am and we
have no editors we have two very
talented editors but that's all we have
yeah we put him on the important stuff
and that it was kind of a Halloween
episode and once Halloween was gone it
was no yeah I think you guys should put
it out there we will and then also give
the audience tasks to re-edit it to be
better that's fun we should just put all
the raw footage out yeah yeah that's how
you get free editors i Lee and I met as
there any other ideas like trivia bday
that have been suggested on repeat that
you guys haven't collectively got on
board about I want to do a video where
Steve and I handcuff ourselves to each
other for 24 hours and it's a big trend
on YouTube yeah oh really
is it really it was yeah for sure it was
like couples and friends handcuffing
each other I just don't want to do it so
you guys are on trend without even
knowing yeah no we don't we're not up to
speed yeah I definitely still want to do
it I think it'd be very funny and I
wanted to do it on a night that I had
like a stand-up show and have to like
drag Steve onstage but Steve has we'd
also have to like sleep together yeah
there's a lot of complications as we
started like we were we had it all
scheduled and then we like REI still
think it'd be fine oh and then skydiving
I still just there's a lot of like
experiential stuff we want to do one
base I want to solve a can yeah we can
get out of the office I want to leave it
you should just take a vacation yes
that's what I need to do is
out of town I think and this is me now
just voluntarily EP your guys this whole
channel now that you guys should do more
experience on things I think it's fun to
see you guys work together well or not
well yeah we enjoy it it's it's I think
we struggle with what every other
youtuber struggles with on a like a
subconscious level that affects your
decisions and it's like oh we got to get
this stuff out yeah and if we're not
staying on our schedule and some of that
has got to be an office got to knock
this crap out I can and you go if you go
do an experiment yes experiential thing
it just takes so much time and it's so
much footage yeah it's a lie right and
it's fun and it's worth it if you guys
go skydiving just buy the package where
they cut and edit edit a video for you
on site which they do at those places
and they are not to you know toot their
horn too much pretty good at it
star wipe before they are not at a
minimum in the we do that and take that
video and like embedded and actually
answer the question there's other things
Elliott has a narrative podcast he wants
to do
don't be cool yeah yes I do I have a
podcast called work sucks that I want to
do where I interview people about just
their employment history and like it was
you on my party Jay Max fitting room I
watch adult women actually openly but
that was they were going with six
clothes that come out with three they
don't know I got a three-way with this
tags coming out their back and I was
like sixteen I was like not my place I'm
not mrs. max I don't need to save the
day above your pay already interesting I
don't know how to make this show then
after a month I got a $0.50 race offer
from Chili's to host there and that was
my favorite restaurant and I thought I
am peaking at 16 who knew and it was
still when restaurants were smoking or
non was t.j.maxx your first job first Oh
other than like babysitting yeah yeah
what was your first job I worked as a
construction worker for my father
construction company and my job was to
clean up the grounds and I got really
hot oh you had to pick up like the nails
and [ __ ] I did that as 8 year old and
then I worked at a sandwich shop called
crispers
[Laughter]
good it's a storytelling mine was I was
a lifeguard at 15 for a waterslide Park
oh that sounds I would dates everywhere
did you ever have to save a life as I
have I saved children that were up like
trapped underneath like like my Levi's
humans on like river rides river ride
would be where you're on a tube yeah
yeah and lazy river yeah yeah a lot of
that like I'd be a lot of pulling out we
had people airlifted out of this what
people get hurt on water sites what's
going on in Montana where every
waterpark two training courses on CPR
yeah that was the big job for cuz there
was a Swim Club like in the town over
and so that was like a big draw of a job
for all these like teens that I went to
high school with that they were all
lifeguards but I was like I don't think
I trust that dude to save me if I'm
drowning right now hmm
hey we're responsible for it have you
been to you haven't been I don't think
have you been to the Six Flags water
park yeah yeah
have you done this the one where you get
into like the refrigerator looking thing
and then you in it the floor falls out
yeah and you go straight down we did a
trivia show for Smosh on that slide
where if you got the question wrong you
yeah it turns out you have an itch pain
yeah that that slides terrifying yeah
it's fun anyone good times okay well
we're gonna take one more quick break
and let me get back we have Twitter
questions for you guys ever heard of it
how are we doing you know let's give you
an exit survey on the way out after well
Barry back up more might not too deep
after this
[Music]
too deep hey guys let's get something
straight your teeth smile direct Club
straightens your teeth for 60% less than
braces with invisible aligners sent
directly to you simply go online and
book a free 3d scan at one of their
smile shops or order an at-home
impression kit then they'll email a
preview of your new smile and once you
get your aligners one of smile direct
club's duly licensed doctors will check
in on your progress every 90 days visit
smell direct club.com for real
before-and-after photos from some of
five hundred and fifty thousand plus
satisfied grin errs that's cute
satisfied grin errs and exclusive for
our listeners you can get $100 off your
invisible aligners when you go to smile
direct Club comm / podcasts and use
offer code grace 100 you'll also get a
$25 Amazon gift card with a free 3d scan
at one of their smile shops or a $25
rebate on an at-home impression kit
that's $100 off at smile direct Club
comm slash podcast offer code grace 100
smile direct Club calm / podcast offer
code grace 100 this episode of not too
deep is brought to you by drop it's a
free app that gives out cash rewards for
the shopping you do every single day
link your debit and credit cards when
you sign up
select the stores you shop with the most
and earn points each time you spend
there redeem points for gift cards to
places like Amazon Sephora Lululemon and
many more with drop you can earn and
redeem from brands that are entirely
relevant to you and your preferences
you're able to earn across a number of
brands so you accumulate points quickly
especially since the brand's you're
earning points from are the ones you
spend with every day it's easy to link
your cards and then earn points whenever
you spend the app works in the
background to recognize your
transactions and reward you for those
purchases every time and for a limited
time you can head to the App Store or
Google Play and sign up for drop using
my code grace and you'll receive a $10
star
bucks gift card right away make sure to
link a debit or credit card to the app
when you sign up to redeem your reward
okay I'm speaking of very funny we will
god damn lot of Twitter questions for
you guys but before we get into those I
want to ask you guys the two questions
asked every single guest that's on the
podcast Elia I don't know what your
answers were for these last time but
let's see so the first question is who
alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at is that the one
course not offended - first of all -
soon I just wanted to be honest I have
no clue who that would be
cold spaghetti so that I'm assuming I'm
angry at this person it's your own
emotional intention okay cool
all right I can be celebratory it's just
how you I'm definitely in an angry way
okay it's harmless but that's the other
problem it's harmless so is it a joke
cause if are you flirting we do one of
y'all I would do either you lecie I mix
sorry let it yeah hurtful but I think
you'd be a funny response I think I
think I trust my friends enough that if
I were to throw cold spaghetti at them
they would make me laugh but it does
seem mean if your bday ever goes you
know off its rocker and doesn't work
anymore the idea of seeing someone get
hit with cold spaghetti from a
mysterious hand off-camera I'm just
saying has huge entertainment value it's
a pie in the face it's classified
it's 29 but it's more it's more it's
plastic yes I can silly but they will
never go okay the the freaking dumpster
at our office right now has been over
slowly excellent I take about three
weeks to the point no this garbage is
ours by the way none of it and it's only
put on garbage on the Internet it's
overflow has good
it's overflowing into one of our four
parking spaces so now when we have three
mm-hmm and we caught the patellar dude
was parked outside of it you know white
truck you have a picture you could put
it on this pot guys do a picture I took
a picture and I stared him down and he
looked at me yes he did he gave me the
number oh dude I was like I felt yeah I
felt bad you know recently also stared
down a teen that he assumed stole his
pocket the whole time I stared this kid
sound like and I was disappointed and I
was like I think that Kant stole it like
this like tall team you did guess like
me oh yeah I set you up for not success
in that moment yeah and how are you
gonna get those three bouncy balls in a
tootsie roll and that guy's just dumping
all of his stuff does he act I work in
the building no he does not notice he
sees this garbage mess landfill that is
our dumpster and I think we were in a
zone where the garbage never gets picked
they won't pick it up if it's
overflowing and it is overflowing yeah
which is a real problem what do you do
then the solution you live with garbage
dumb internet kids slash adults doing
YouTube that you know everybody else in
the building thinks that were the
athlete yeah they have you guys pegged
as the people that are doing this to
them just a queer [ __ ] in every
other way they think it isn't fair it's
judgment so that's it there's a petition
okay next question
great answer Jeff every single guest on
the podcast is to tell me your worst
pants shooting story or close call but
you can only use three words or three
small phrases or a mix of both to mine
for example college jogging front lawn
I'm gonna use a hyphenated you can do it
ever change just a little bit I'm gonna
use phrases yeah with friends wanted to
be cool Scientology
jumped in air turned 180 to fart whoops
not fart shut my pants falling okay that
was my pants fully that's all that's on
the no fall questions Wow
you know I don't believe that 20 bucks
get your pants on Grace's podcast dude
for real
yeah you're about to see me [ __ ] my
pants I'm making money left and right no
other weird I think I found somebody
else's [ __ ] in underwear one time a
camper in the woods in Florida and I was
like Power Ranger underwear and I was
old enough to be like that's two or
david dobrik first question what the
hell was joe doing rolling sushi at
Gonzaga uh it was my early morning job I
had died this is the college you went to
Gonzaga it's a it's a private Jesuit
university when I play March Madness I
always put them as number one because I
root for an underdog and now they're
always like raided I thought they're
always like 15 um okay we're an hour now
I can't look I know I just need to talk
to me you're fine
private colleges are expensive I got
scholarships and stuff but still had to
make money so I get up at like 6:00 in
the morning and go to the food service
and I'd roll sushi for two hours before
class Oh something about that's oddly
like therapeutic sounding it was it
really was like it was Zen yeah and I
don't like sushi I don't eat it and but
rolling it was kind of nice yeah there's
an art
to it oh I've learned more about you in
this podcast than I have in a while not
cool
hey I used to roll sushi yeah yeah it's
like trivia that like I'm sure you've
said next to me and I just wasn't
listening it yeah I've ever listened to
you thank you when you take an authentic
vested interest in someone sometimes you
can learn things interesting that's
right okay
my college roommate Michelle tweeted and
asked please pontificate on the validity
of your Hogwarts house sorting in great
detail have you guys been sorted because
your fellow valley folk member Lee she's
very well yeah we were unset for a fine
brothers production and she got very up
it is not the right word but very
animated and aggressive about me having
to be sorted into a house cuz that's how
she really truly valued whether she was
gonna be friends with someone and so she
sorted me until it was done and I'm a
Hufflepuff passed her test shoes off so
what do you think we are what do I think
you are I'm gonna say to slytherins
nevermind Ravenclaw's I don't know this
is coming from people that are very
adamant casual party no I think Joe
you're a Gryffindor I was back in the
day I think things change people grow
the stuff at home like there's some dark
health stuff that I've been having to go
through for the past like four years and
I somehow morphed into a ravenclaw see
that I was originally a ravenclaw I
think I haven't taken the test since and
I would imagine I still AM and I'm okay
with that that that's a Hogwarts School
of Witchcraft and Wizardry is that the
sorting hat test is based on the
myers-briggs test it's a personality
yeah and it's very in-depth and it's
very good but it's also it doesn't
doesn't none of those things
a lot because you're just telling a
computer about yourself and then the
computers tells you what you already
told it and then you're like that can't
believe it's me and it's that doesn't it
doesn't doesn't I'm not trying to be a
buzzkill but anyway this is a it's just
proving that I'm a raving two times on
my podcast is the max number of times
strongest [ __ ] that's gonna be a
buzzkill a third time um Goblin Queen
why did you hide the milk that's a you
problem
there was an us problem but I did
totally at the end of that night at the
bar so basically I thought it'd be
hilarious I was slightly inebriated that
after being shown the valley folk office
for the first time to give them a gift
as a thank you and appreciation for what
they do for the community and for
allowing me explore their um their work
rooms like a child at a playground and
so I put a gallon of milk in your office
think he knew about and I literally said
I texted you it's on record like the
next day be like he got get rid of that
milk it was there for a very long time
I'm very long time a series of videos on
a daily basis of him updating me on
where the milk was hidden but then
thought we'd return to the G to be fair
to be fair that first gallon of milk was
there for a long time Elliott knew about
it it was on a ground level globe you
know this type of globes that you can
open up that are classy alcohol and it
becomes a liquor cabinet yeah we never
it opened it up so there was a gallon of
milk in there for a very long time yeah
and it was more of a lesson of like you
guys should utilize these beautiful
coochie months that you have in your
office why is no one utilizing I know it
was a lesson for us to learn thank you
it's like a completely responsible adult
lesson to teach you guys then we we went
out to a Grayson I went to a fancy sushi
restaurant
yeah I do dude I do know that I must
listen we were there and and grace was
like I think I think that's Justin
Bieber in the corner anyway I was living
too bougie of a life at that moment that
I needed to balance the universe and go
get up to impractical mischief yeah and
so we went into a TV show well I had
also been telling you about this recent
this prank that I heard when I was like
I was a college or high school like
legendary senior prank thing where they
in my South Jersey area it's a lot of
farmland there and so this one college
had this prank that no one knows if it's
real but they put four sheep into the
school they labeled them one two three
five yeah my son shushing creativity
right your grand you can also make a
cameo appearance if you want to sing and
this is how grace becomes friends with
children sing it for me silent on there
yeah and so Elliott like sad so we went
and we bought four milks and labeled
them one two three five along with some
firewood and a lot of tickets a lot of
tickets which to me was a pure gift it
was one of them one I think this might
we might not have found all of a lot of
tickets
mmm-hmm we did I think yeah I spoil
everything find all the milks now you'll
see where this story is going went
perfectly it went perfectly listen to me
perfectly it was exactly what the Lord
intended grace saw she hit him
everywhere and then she was like see if
you can find him gonna look there there
there and she was like okay go out and
I'll hide him again so she hit him all
again and then completely forgot were
all over them more to be fair we all
went to a bar shortly after and I
remember at the end of the night telling
you you're like where's the last milk
and I was like I'm really bothered by
this - I don't know I'm pretty sure it's
in the ceiling somewhere
went to the show checked everywhere in
the ceiling looked and then I read it
was everything it was the best it was
the it was exact it was like
orchestrated for me by the Lord hold up
before you keep going grace this is a
microcosm of our
office because this is just trivia bidet
all over again nobody else was looking
for the milk and the ceiling yeah oh no
I was like let's let it hang was own
nature take its course a couple of days
I'd be like can you please actually go
look for the milk I feel awful yeah no I
definitely and then I started just
convincing myself that we'd found all
the milk which we hadn't found and I
knew deep down but and then we're
filming and Steve comes in and to the
room in the middle of shooting some
videos hey it smells like legitimately
something died in the podcast room and
in my head coming back - yeah and it's
because if supposedly died and then in
my head I was like it's the milk and
then we as it takes her like another ten
second I'm staying very silent and then
ten seconds fast and Lea just goes maybe
it's that [ __ ] milk well yeah it
could be the milk turns out it's exactly
the milk and it comes a lot easier to
discover which part of the ceiling the
milk is concealed behind when there is a
big stain in one of the ceiling tiles I
couldn't watch it but I just got an all
caps text from Elliott that goes grace
and then what looked like you balanced
on a chair going into the ceiling and I
was like I know it's the milk I haven't
watched the video I already feel awful
about this
it was like the most representative
experience for all of us because your
first instinct when you saw it was to
blame yourself
the fact that I'm just enamored by how
wonderful every all this [ __ ] is and
then Steve is bursting out laughs and
going well it's funny about that video
though is that you see me on the
precipice of that couch about to fall
out a window yeah and from two stories
up and if you think about it that's
where she was
definitely I fell hard I was very drunk
trying to get these milks headed and
when you found them so quickly I was
like I can do better
oh it's like I just fell down I fell off
a chair but they're all hitting guilt
yeah yeah because it didn't explode it
was about to Italy just enough for us to
smell it and we got most of it up yes
everything turned out fine it turns out
hiding milk in people's offices is what
some may call a harmless prank okay
someone to know if there were any limits
budget otherwise what kind of video
would you guys love to make I definitely
do a like a film I would do like a whole
thing I'd do a whole or whole series but
it would be like scripts and narratives
very vague movie listen alright there's
this movie that I'm working on and it's
called it's with Steve Leary plays a
genie but catching any of unconscious
wishes and it's basically he he grants
wishes but they're like the inner desire
like the deepest desires of the person
and and that's what I want that would be
my my thing but it only needs a budget
of like 15 grand I think like deep down
we all came here in one way or another
to make movies and more scripted stuff
yeah but like you know on a big level
you know yeah that's it but I guess like
if it's a straight-up video that's not
really answering the question is a video
or a movie yeah if it's a video I I
answered this when you asked before I
wanted to do a video in a movie once
just a longer video so yes I we I kind
of answered this before when Elliott
brought it up I want to make a like a
Buster Keaton esque silent film a very
physical thing
yes choreographed and fun and kind of
like a throwback and a love letter to
that but with I think that's awesome
yeah yeah that's a good answer Jo it's
better than my stupid
we're gonna I mean this is gonna just be
Joe Bereta son not to drop it out so
it's a no who wrote that everyone goes
to therapy skit yeah that was me why why
why curious about that it's very sweet
Julianne yeah yeah they just wanted to
know I really I can't respond to them on
these cards yeah no I did that when I
was I was a good one okay what's the
weirdest mein kampf you've ever gotten
for your show we get serious ones a fair
amount that are always kind of
interesting we really know how to handle
those you guys just did an episode where
it was just you guys and Steve and I
listen to that podcast episode and it
was really because it was way more
serious and Joe you opened up a lot
about your personal life and I was just
like a really nice conversation to
listen to of like three adult men really
hearing each other for like what seemed
like the first time and like supporting
each other it was just like in a world
littered with toxic masculinity and all
that nonsense it was just like a very
refreshing nice thing to hear and it
feels like you guys have the ability to
lean into that we do it's uncomfortable
because it's oh yeah even herbal yeah we
did by your your suggestion and or your
your your encouragement we did the eye
contact video the pairings for that it
was me and Lee and it was super
emotional and then it was Steve and Joe
doing fart noises just we went for it
but it's like Steve just couldn't yeah
so but that's also interesting and
telling to watch someone avoid the
emotional intimacy that comes from that
because if you guys don't know there's
this BuzzFeed video that when I went you
jus viral years ago called four minutes
of uninterrupted eye contact as opposed
to like promote this new level of
intimacy between strangers and you know
people that been married for their you
know entire lives which is us
the valley folk has been married yeah
but I know I've been married for six
years I think yeah it's true but the
emotional dynamics I think are really
fun it is we're going into it more but
it's also so like it's just too much
sometimes yeah we know each other so
well that it's like you like how you're
saying that's like fish eye
exactly if we don't listen to each other
we're just around each other all the
time and so yeah podcast like that or
hearing that you rolled sushi it's like
there's a little bit of pay attention
when you talk yeah we have a just enough
we we don't give a fox and also like
don't want to worry about the Edit that
most things get through the filter and
not to get to pee are taki pointing
bullcrap or whatever we really do
believe in like with what we're trying
to create this this world of friendship
with our audience and transparency you
get a little bit of everything so I
think we're we're very comfortable I
think with putting the the more like
emotional [ __ ] out yeah a lot of
questions for you guys or basically
about like what parts of your personal
life you decide that you're comfortable
including in your online persona
presence etcetera I mean at this point I
don't really I feel like I have the
freest wall yeah you're the most the
most but you also have a family like
this yeah yeah that's my wall I mean
it's like oh yeah well there's a that's
a protection thing because that you if
you put something out on the internet
you're never gonna be able to take it
back so it's better I think to be a
little bit more conservative yeah I
think there's a curation that I do that
that I'm comfortable with most of the
time but sometimes it feels inauthentic
and bothers me like on an existential
level that again don't need a deep dive
into but for as far as my family goes
Eliot says and many other people have
been like where's your family vlog you
guys would blow up and it's just weird
to me it's not a world I want to get
into or I want to clarify I'm not I
would never pushy doesn't put you
exploitation of a loving family my
suggestion was like I respect Joe as a
creator and a comedian and I believe
that if he had the opportunity to like
reframe the vlog the family vlog
environment if I'm not gonna do it if
you could do it with myself
yes Godspeed to anybody that can do it I
think there's there's effects that can
happen years down the line that people
are not realizing yet I don't feel like
I should make the decision nope for my
kids before they can an impression of a
healthy father like imagine
just your own experience doing this for
10 years and how it messes with our head
I'm the star
okay and the last question before we
wrap up that so many people asked in so
many different ways is what's the
hardest thing about starting the valley
folk or the most important thing that
you've learned it last year because I
feel like with the sugar pine sevens of
the world and people and like the david
dobrik there's a lot of kids that really
want to work with their friends and want
to work in the digital space with their
friends and I think it's scary for a lot
of people so has there been one primary
piece of information that's really
changed the way you guys work together
it's been like educational I've learned
a lot I think my biggest takeaway has
been like at first it was like we're
doing a business and we're gonna be
business people and now I feel like a
year into it it's like I think I was
very wrong and I think it's like we have
to actually ironically for the business
to flourish we have to ignore a lot of
that stuff yeah just focus on literally
hanging out and trying to make each
other laugh and so that is kind of I
think that that has more value yeah
that's more valuable than us being less
decision to make and when we put our
business hats on I think we we get a
little bit in our own heads and insane
distance between you guys yeah and so I
think we found to like with like live
performances and stuff and traveling
together and like being hunkered down
elsewhere outside of LA it has helped us
form a bond that I think is showing in
the product that we're making
you're really pushing this get out of LA
things I know it's right yeah I think
that would be the big thing is just
returning to being a troupe of
fun-loving weirdos is gonna be the the
secret there's gonna be cracks you have
to be okay with maybe it's not gonna
work out in the end not just the
business but the friendships we luckily
enough had a history yeah you know not
just with each other but with trying to
do this industry trying to do business
well that was us owning it yeah we
support each other's deficiencies we
also have deficiencies that's a great
phrase
Elly and I work together well enough
because since SourceFed we've been
honest enough to like on the days we
piss each other off
it's the literally the best marriage we
have because we immediately tell each
other that [ __ ] you yeah you [ __ ] you
because [ __ ] you because and then right
yep and then we move on
sometimes grace this might shock you I
think I'm right all the time I think I'm
right
I can occasionally come off like an
[ __ ] and Joe is very good about being
he will literally do a [ __ ] you think
you're right right now and I understand
that you think you're right you're right
in many ways so [ __ ] you for saying that
hey um [ __ ] you know yeah we move on the
moment that Joe and I I think became
like really good friends was some kind
of thing at SourceFed we got into some
[ __ ] fight and I it was the first like
dude friendship experience I think it
had like this where like we walked in or
I walked into the editing room he was
like on the flaying on the floor doing
like you know just being whatever and
and I was like hey man I was like a
sorry about that and he was like yeah
I'm sorry about that too I was like are
we good he's like yeah well and it's
been like that Everest with very intense
conversations and sporadic it's scary I
don't know I think I think it can work I
think we've been lucky so far I think
our situation is unique and I don't want
to dismiss that in the sense that our
foundation is created by a bunch of very
very generous people that have given us
a financial backing that lets us take
dumb risks yes and that is different
from just going into a garage with your
friends with no financial backing and
making a huge life decisions yeah I
think that should tears people apart way
quicker it gave us and kind of yeah like
a mental freedom to be like oh we can't
be yeah yeah yeah we're doing the small
business stuff all wrong
like all of our decisions if you were a
business major you'd be like how how is
this working you shouldn't be doing what
you're doing that's great I don't know
what my advice is tread carefully try to
have fun there's some idealistic
bullcrap nice yeah I think the most
cliched things sometimes are
the most helpful reminders for people
don't do YouTube I'm thinking there's so
much for making time thank you guys
every one of the guests on the podcast
get a personalized fortune cookie from
personalized okay jokes hey Jackson you
want to open a fortune cookie come here
it's pretty cool and I wouldn't eat them
cuz it might be kind of stale but they
technically are edible we have an extra
one that you can have when you're okay
and you're done he's nobody's problem oh
he's not gonna be exploited yes this is
like a wet this cookies real wet
is it supposed to tear open hey it's
been raining in LA oh it is it's moist
yeah thank you where you keeping these
fortune cookies alright I'm unfolding
mine here where you guys do a thing
where you have to say something at like
the end of the phrase no not an embed
situation okay what is it take your
vagus and mindset
oh my inside here's is a novel if you do
a really good impression of grace right
now will officially declare you the
better guests over Elliot for Tuesday's
episode Wow
today's episode is that you say Tuesdays
did your brain put 2 today for today's
episode it all over again just on the
top will do you do a really good
impression of grace right now will
officially declare you the better guests
over Elliot for Tuesday's episode
perfect well let's see what you got
you don't have to because you can just
declare Elliot the better guest no no I
definitely was not the better guest to
us
[Music]
now I okay thank you for watching and
listening this episode of not Judy I'll
see you guys next week--goodbye a shower
2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer and edited
by melissa demons writing by diane kang
a production assistants by Katrina
Henning post production sound by
Christopher Bell and an extra special
thanks to Flula for the theme music
[Music]